[Music]
hi you're gonna be late okay you okay
yeah thanks mom a lab is only as good as
its leaders somebody help me hey leave
him alone
a true king is brave and noble don't be
a hero on the King around here you have
more battles yet to fight you must
choose what you stand for varus scores
he was found something written on the
guard put it into google translate it
means sort of Arthur what if you're the
only person who could have pulled that
sort out what if it's Excalibur
ah finally follow me
I am Merlin someone who's pushed me in a
wash an ingenious disguise do you think
in four days the dark sorcerer Morgana
will take over the world just ridiculous
there's your sore back and good luck
with everything
you're a king Alexander the sword chose
you
why would we help you because you're the
strongest people I know you're my
Knights
and this is the round table quick
butters lift up the flaps oh my god
you're such a nerd
this is this
this is like an every story we have
already Luke Skywalker Harry Potter
something amazing happens they find out
they descended from magical families mom
don't freak out okay
all hail the once and future king please
don't
it's embarrassing
what did you drive Mario Kart
[Music]
you